Speaker 1: I have an incredible story for
you here. This is a story not only of of
potential domestic violence, sadly, but also
yet again of the projection that is they are
going to commit voter fraud. We have now
learned of a man whose wife is missing and
he is a suspect in her disappearance who
has pled guilty to casting her ballot for
Trump in 2020. This is the voter fraud that
they claim exists exclusively on the left.
And yet law enforcement seems to only be able
to find Republicans committing voter fraud.
The Hill reports a man with missing wife pleads
guilty to casting her ballot for Trump in 2020.
A man who was tried in connection to his
wife's disappearance pleaded guilty Thursday
to submitting a fraudulent ballot on her behalf
for Trump during the 2020 election. This is
Berry Morphew, who said to law enforcement he
figured all these other guys are cheating. My
wife Suzanne would have voted for Trump,
so I'm going to submit a ballot for her.
The defendant was arrested in May of 2021, but was
already in police custody because of his suspected
role in his wife's disappearance. The suspicion
is he killed his wife. Morphew was offered a plea
deal allowing charges of attempting to influence a
public servant and elections offense to be dropped
if he pled guilty to the forgery charge. He faces
a year of supervised probation for the charge.
The murder case against Barry Morphew was
dismissed without prejudice after Suzanne
Morphew, whose body was unable to be located.
So understand that we have no particular reason
to think he didn't kill his wife. There just was
no body. And in this particular case, there was
not enough of a circumstantial case. Sometimes
you see murder cases go forward with no body,
and sometimes you even see guilty verdicts with
no body. But in this case, there was no such case
to be made. Suzanne Morphew disappeared in May
of 2020 and has not been recovered. However,
law enforcement said last year they believe they
are close to discovering the victim's body. Think
about that, he said to law enforcement. Listen,
everybody else is cheating. I know my wife would
have voted for Trump. So I decided to submit the
vote for her anyway. That's a crime. Okay, maybe
the wife didn't really want to vote for Trump
and he killed her and then voted for Trump in
her name. Maybe we don't really know. Understand
the projection that is constantly happening.
Republican leaders and Trump spend 2020 saying
there is massive fraud happening by Democrats.
And so some Republican voters say, screw it. If
the Democrats are going to cheat, we're going
to cheat, too. And then law enforcement shows
up and says, we don't find any Democrats doing
this. We only are able to find Republicans doing
some to, quote, test the system and some because
they are just genuinely committing voter fraud.
The very voter fraud that they say is the left,
that is that that is being committed by the
left. These people are incredible. And if they
are allowed to do it again, they will. And if
they're able to succeed, we're really screwed